[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
when we talk about whatever we want
jazzy yeah that's the new after record
song I'm gonna have a new one every time
we do it that's tight yeah I think we're
I think we all really like it right yeah
yeah I've been posting more consistently
on my channel again I'm feeling the butt
plug yeah I know you guys you guys I've
been seeing more content on podcast
every week yeah you could check out baby
Leia you see there Steve's channel has
the podcast clips of the podcaster yes
sir
Nicky's channel she recently did that a
best leches cake yeah on my side
dude no seriously for the longest time
my videos didn't pop up in anyone's
feeds and subscribers are like I never
see your video the evening has been
happy that's us too and in YouTube
swears there's nothing going on yeah I
think I think I figured it out though
because he it started popping back up in
his channel it's true and it was after I
did this like channel analytics thing
with a guy that's really good at SEO and
stuff and we tested it with this one
video and it showed up in his feed and
then it started it kept showing up in
people's feeds because people were
clicking on it so that first hour is
super important if people don't click on
your video when YouTube promotes it and
suggested video pulls it to your own
people your own subscribers even
notification and if they click the bell
a [ __ ] belt like I can't get over
like why they need to go through so many
[ __ ] steps to watch this I know and
we could be a YouTube right now and
saying all this to the engineers and
they're all like that doesn't happen
yeah same as it ever was
thumbnails and titles are more important
than any content because people have to
click on it and if they don't then
you're [ __ ] you're no one's ever gonna
see that video so are you saying it's
time to bring back the titty thumbnails
but but
those get flag that you victim on oh
there yeah we got you by the balls and
your audience because you can't say like
controversial things or you got to
change the titles and we do that a lot
now JK news because like some other
[ __ ] hilarious anything you can't
even say like what it is because we'll
get D monitor I love dad gets ended by
his son yeah after our cuz you how do
you post describe a murder I don't know
it's like you crying at this man's
ending yeah but you know what though
there's this one girl recently like I
found she hid the algorithm jackpot so
this girl she's [ __ ] funny I'm like
her biggest fan now her name is Joanna
Joanna Joanna Cydia and I'm sure a lot
of people who watch you two have found
out about her because she's going viral
based on the fact that she hid algorithm
gold like for some reason YouTube kept
promoting her videos like crazy and like
she just started her channel two months
ago
oh how many subscribers right now 2
million ok not that crazy but she's 675
thousand did you month
in two months Wow congratulations girls
she's [ __ ] funny she deserves every
second me and I like so she's like this
seventeen-year-old girl from Canada like
I said I've been watched all her video
so I know everything about her okay I
love her more because she reminds me a
lot of my cousin Roxanna and her name is
Roxana
and Joanna are like they both start with
the seat don't pass out slow down and
they both wear the glasses you sound
like a bad girl but anyway she's so
[ __ ] funny like her editing is like
old YouTube I guess though wait wait so
how did she hit algorithm jackpot
because she do that mean it was this one
particular video she's titled it I di
wide Emma Chamberlain's new clothing
line and that video has 3.3 million
views like first summer eat like no one
knows what it is that she did but for
some reason she just [ __ ] skyrocketed
like cruise can't what happened to
gentle mom was none beginning she did
like how to tell when people
so how do prick people into thinking
that you're hot and do anything you're
good-looking and they went not naughty
naughty viral yeah we're talking like 20
million or in every video after that she
just kept going viral yeah
yeah but like this girl she's nothing
really new like if you've been watching
YouTube for all like you know this whole
decade I think game-changing it's
nothing game-changing he's just like she
just somehow figured it out and like
she's just blowing up right now so for
the most top five like it's nothing
really that new if you think about it
like since the inception of YouTube like
the Ryan Higa style the what's his name
the raywilliamjohnson style the very
even like what Jenna Marbles did awesome
[ __ ] gentlemen
well Shane Dawson is doing something
very different now yeah it's my theory
on Shane Dawson so because he has great
thumbnails and titles like click baby a
type of thumbnails and titles but it's
not clickbait because he's actually
doing the thing that I'm really good in
the comments really good yeah
and it's long the watch time also
matters so that's how our buddy came up
if your videos not long YouTube also
doesn't push it because it can't get ad
revenue then our buddy totally sketch
was coming up he basically was like he
saw the need for like actually
delivering on palmdale so he what he did
was he got like a bunch of hot people
and started putting him and like hot
girls and stuff and put him in videos
and just like actually did it whereas
like back then I was like lisanova had
titties but she didn't do anything with
them like now there's a titty thumbnail
and there's things happening with the
cities in the video you know actually I
first saw you guys do their Gitty
thumbnails and I was in the thumbnail
sure probably and I know shop titties
but we had we have thumbnails that are
just cleavage
yeah like hell of you do yeah it has
like millions of you ever won every
fileted from DeFranco video was just
titties everywhere called it the philip
defranco thumbnails
that was great but I remember you're the
one that got these he convinced me to
start playing the game so all my Q&A s
there's always like one sexual question
so I would put a sexual question in not
answer it sexually but then use a sexual
thumbnail from the internet from Google
not my body brought us America person's
body I sued all my tough talks I would
do some hot-ass [ __ ] thumbnail on
every tough talk and it's just my stupid
ass talking yeah but that's why
everyone's channels got to monetize like
Steve doesn't make a dime no not out
[ __ ] and I mean cuz all of his
thumbnails and we're like that every one
of my videos got do monitor yeah really
pretty pretty classic day yeah you know
what I just realized
- I just realized that Instagram changed
a 13-2 because I remember like recently
I posted something and I was telling
that I was trying to reply to someone in
the comments telling them like Oh check
out the link in my comment I mean in my
bio and YouTube blocked me from posting
that comment right oh wait cuz you give
them a link oh wait you posted a youtube
comment with a loop - no services
Instagram on Instagram comments I was
telling someone in my own comments check
out the link in my bio and Instagram
blocked me from posting that what like
what the [ __ ] you can't tell people to
look at the link in my bio every word in
it well wonder what the keyword I don't
even know how to rework like check burn
and let in how would you title it for a
JK news video
so I edit videos and then when we put
them up we'll name I'm usually something
like I think it's pretty tame or
whatever but just has a whole list like
we've literally been sent a list of nono
words and then she'll go through them
and be like can't use this one and so
like take them out and then replace them
with just like the most like bland
sounding like if you could put like I
got a list from YouTube that like if
these you put these words in the title
then for sure it's gonna get D monetized
yeah or the tags they have the other
list where you can put it in and it gets
you more man I wish yeah it just has to
be stuff that people are searching yeah
you should be the house like how to yeah
but now I don't think it's any of those
things but you know vid IQ is really
good there's this boring III got be
monetized I got D monetize with the
video I did with Julia and it's the
title is how not to get friend-zoned mmm
oh yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] we
did wrong and it's still D monetize I it
it a request and then YouTube even
tweeted at me and said like we'll look
into it they never responded and I got
these monetized on one I have no idea
what I did the video is called hot girl
shits on a bed it pops up I like my
suggesting yourself yes that's a good
one
you should check it out Nikki right yeah
I didn't do okay dookey going in between
the legs so I thought it was your legs
my legs are much browner okay but that
one's about how guys are so desperate
even when a girl shits themselves Estero
just will try to [ __ ] her and they
really do still try it's amazing yeah do
you ever think about doing videos again
like this I want you I just don't know
economically how to make it cuz because
always to have a production budget
I don't used to make money off your
videos and in maker studios used to help
you shoot it and all that stuff and I
didn't make [ __ ] [ __ ] off of my
channel I always just put that money
right back into making more videos
always but but it was going great and
then yeah
wholesale demagnetizer and then Venice
Beach also like makes you get a permit
now to shoot everyone did it yeah geez
videos yeah those are great
yeah great so yeah I want to do I want
to do stuff but it's tough in the
current climate of YouTube a lot of
thing has changed and I think like some
people they survive and they fight
through or like they figure it out and
then now it's like survival like I
always say like people that go through
this phase of trying to do entertainment
or do something for yourself right like
like you find a little bit of success
and then you kind of ride that but then
when things change you also have to just
be able to adapt yeah because we have a
lot of friends that like that started
old school like we're old school YouTube
like around 2007 whatever right so like
throughout the years we've seen some
people [ __ ] blow up and then crash
and disappear or like some people blow
up but they they figured you know this
is not for them and they'll get going to
business or other things like it's a
miracle that we're still here it
honestly is well see we don't were just
talking about this yesterday that like
oh good thing our channels never blew up
because like we've never gone down cuz
you can't be a husband if you've never
been a hat so you can never just succeed
if we we do not want it no I'm terrified
of that level of success cuz then it's
like oh [ __ ] in fact when I first went
viral viral like were millions like I
got a hundred thousand subscribers in a
day Brett hosted the railing on Johnson
show and then like my videos were all
getting pumped with like millions of
views and [ __ ] I was never more scared
to post a video than the next video I
was going is it goes of the new fans
yeah cuz Union you don't want to let
them down now that now there's an
expectation right of what you're gonna I
actually like how we grow kind of like
slow yeah cuz that means that the people
that are watching and following they
really like I saw it into a subscribing
and I've seen other people's like other
youtubers fans and whatever right like
when we have meet and greets it's normal
ass people you know it's it's like
regular
college students like it's not crazy
[ __ ] weirdos or like super super
young children or like you know what I
mean it's a few weirdos I mean that's
that's gonna be anyway anything but it's
not nothing I've seen other youtubers
fans and meet and greet and smelled them
my friend yeah I've been around how long
all of our friends have are a lot of
most of them have like younger
demographics so at like VidCon and stuff
they have like tons of fans but they're
all like eight they're like [ __ ] people
are like the [ __ ] Dragon Queen like
like above them all like like yes my but
then then they walk around like big-time
and other people were just like dude
you're [ __ ] bunch of three-year-olds
or Julia oh yeah you're like you're like
40-something and seven year olds are
just [ __ ] worshiping you you know it
sucks is like brands will like go to
them before they go to any of us and
then they it gets to their head and
they're all smug about it that's why
it's hilarious yeah I'm not giving it to
you on brand say about Walmart over
DiGiorno you can buy her mouth the
brands that promote advertising that's
the point it's better it's better it is
better but that's why I feel like
thankful though when we do have meet and
greets and ice and I meet them and I'm
like thank you you're so [ __ ] normal
you're so cool fans man anytime we've
gotten stuff because of JK like burp you
are like I love killing Jacob they're
always like normal college-age yeah yeah
people who are your friends oh like that
age my might I have a crisscross of
people who are there because they know
what I'm doing and people who are there
cuz I probably trolled them in some way
and so cuz I told my audience like half
of the time on YouTube huh happen to be
more like yo man what the [ __ ] like I
thought you were gonna post a bunch of
more porn star vids right and then a
bunch of people are like hey man where's
all the old [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] so
it'sit's tough because I I use trolling
my own crowd for so long and then i
trolled a lot of the Rey people that
came over to Trader Joe's employees that
was tasty Tuesday feminize not even
sponsored by them don't need money to
say I love Trader Joe's we're at a
seafood restaurant I and some very nice
people came over having watched the JK
stuff oh yeah that's done we've loved
running into fans whenever we're
traveling because that's yeah and they
pop in the weirdest places to like I'll
be on trip work trips from my other job
sometimes and then I'll get stopped and
be like hey you're that guy from like
you know some on some of the videos like
[ __ ] what are you doing here I like I
don't want to bother you while you're
eating and I'm like well you just
[ __ ] okay no because I was just had
to bite in my mouth no no because I
really don't care like I really don't
mind like it's I've been with McGee for
you know you're begging this yeah thank
you
no no it's always very nice though so
funny but of course is that a seafood
restaurant we do a lot of Mexican
restaurants oh you're saying cuz the
Asian peoples from yeah
it's always agent Mary your people we
went to so many Mexican restaurant they
come to meet in our budget oh we got a
lot of Mexicans cuz we're a family
channel and they all have kids are young
you know she's Mexican town I have a lot
of kids and you
early 20s and have kids and you know
young bee want tube Hey agents have 1.1
kids 1.1.1 what does one point wise
statistically like it's always like that
right it's like 1.35 Jack what does that
mean like a 1.5 it's not like a it's not
like a bathroom in the house average
okay this is really connected to the
human condition reading this statistic
right is pictured like one teenager in
one like toddler 1.5 kids men from the
from the famous chefs you enough men
that kid grew up and it was just like
three men they should change the name of
the show I'm really changed sitting for
that show two guys the girl in a pizza
place oh yeah guys know it was with
Brian Romano it's his first gig I guess
that was the first time I like Rick
Bobby was cute
I was on NBC at 9:30 I never know the
network but it was like two guys a girl
at a pizza place and then they just
started be like two guys at a girl
why don't you two guys the reason why do
networks I think that we have loyalty
can I ask that like NBC's like uh NBC
you like the peacock we met and that's
like CBS is like a CBS that's where you
got to go like we love you how to love
CBS but I'm always like I don't feel any
affinity towards we're all wearing like
CBS shirts right exactly but they all
think that is it a news thing because
like they'll have like news news
programming rights and there's like
certain channels that you trust more for
your news no but it's the thing that
they're digging into you know but the
commercials I'm talking about are always
for their sitcom II [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
right like to it like like like I liked
Fox growing up because of Mary watch
Mary with children and sim Simpson
that's the only reason why I loved Fox
right I didn't know anything else about
like Fox name yeah I didn't know about
Fox News I know any about anything about
that and then WB is where I like family
matters yes no yes head family matters
OTB yeah
cable no no it was on WB channel 5 1 la
yeah I used to watch it every day I wish
CW had a news channel or had a news show
it's like hey well CW news we're hot
[ __ ] kids
no you're not I mean good morning KTLA
you're so [ __ ] technical minded the
[ __ ] game used to be UPN technically
because you grew up in LA that's why
[Laughter]
they didn't see any of that by the way
so that was not really working really
wait those channels still exist yes I
don't watch TV we don't even have TV but
I mean - Hulu with live TV a few months
ago sponsor Brendon no I'm not but it's
a brand I thought but I really loved it
yeah so if they were to come along with
you know so I I got it a few months ago
and I tried to watch it as much as I can
so I'm like I'm paying $40 a month for
this way but I realize like I'm just
there's just no use I was I was so you
know the the purge is now like on TV
right yeah yes okay thank God
so now I forgot what network it was on
but then it had commercials then I
couldn't skip I was sitting here and
it's like a hunch and there's a
countdown and he'll tell you like 116
seconds of ads and I'm just sitting
there like I can't take this anymore
I gotta [ __ ] buy it like I can't I
just this adds driving me crazy I hate I
think I can't go back to regular TV
because I'm so spoiled with like no ads
we're gonna do the digital box where
your TiVo yeah the TV the fast-forward
it yes he recorded
because that's the reason why Bart and
geo got cable again because they miss
commercials what are you talking about
it's the weirdest thing I've ever heard
that's not why the next sounds like Bart
trolling you know that's what they said
well if that's what you're saying
geo said does she miss comers like I
just miss commercials maybe she misses
evolve Bart's watching us animation on
cable and she's often got commercial
yeah that might be a there's uh what do
you call it like mindless TV sometimes
not bad - just just letting that
background noise play reality TV baby
yeah all day oh I'll watch that [ __ ] all
[ __ ] day okay I can't have things
play in the background I get to sucked
in like I can't let it but it depends on
the kind of content though cuz we the
worst thing ever and I'll still have to
watch it like I watched The Human
Centipede all the way through and I
hated it like five minutes that's cuz we
have really interesting [ __ ] on TV why
are you doing that to yourself you have
that side that's like saying like it's
like there's a documentary about like
what it would be like to be standing on
the surface of Mars and you're like you
like have nothing but you're like I
can't watch it
I can't have in the background I have to
focus on it's like well no [ __ ] that
sounds interest you into like like a
sports channels or like Oh first year
sports please if you play that yeah just
background noise
exactly go I'm too nosy what I need to
know what's happening that's why I can't
have like Judge Judy on cuz I just want
to watch that [ __ ] the whole time judge
you do he's pretty entertaining yes I
just watched this thing on Netflix with
what's-his-name Norman Donald it had
Judge Judy on on it she's so old that I
just kind of changed it and shove your
ass out of it highest paid TV ever and
she's still doing this down yeah the
high 70 million year yeah Wow aunt so
you better chill out over there pal and
I just is always watching her that's how
I got back into it all just like I would
just you could buy your face from your
head I love her to buy my face you know
by your face you because like I need it
you have a lot of money
[Music]